in indonesia's central java this father
endures what no parent should have to
as he grieves for his son unaware was
one of the 53 men
completing a submarine training exercise
in waters near bali
when the vessel named kri nangala 402
lost contact
and sank his younger brother last saw
him
two weeks ago
for me he was perfect everything about
him was good
used to work on another submarine but
was recently reassigned to the kri
nangala 402 in shock and sadness
this community is coming together to
honor his life indonesia's president
joko widodo says the government will
raise the ranks of the sailors
and pay for the education of their
children
they are the best sons of the nation the
best patios guiding the sovereignty of
the country
gracilia's husband rustiancia was one of
the men on board
she gave birth three weeks ago now she
must raise her son without him
i am proud of my husband he did his duty
with open heart
even when he had to leave me and our
small baby
he did his duty well he was the hero to
this country
in bali the family of captain ikede
kartika hopes they will be able to hold
a funeral service for him
we pray to god the body of our nephew
can be retrieved from the sea
so we can perform the rituals it's not
clear if they will get that chance
the submarine was found broken into
three parts almost
850 metres below the ocean's surface
retrieving it will be complex and
indonesian authorities are seeking
guidance from international experts
[Music]
a few months ago the sailors filmed this
video set to a song about saying goodbye
and seeing someone again thousands have
shared the video online as a tribute to
them
[Music]
outside the home of commander harry
satyawan people offer their condolences
to his family
i have to be strong i have to calm my
heart
many people are helping to make me
stronger
in an instant her family was changed
forever when kri nangala 402
disappeared into the depths of the ocean
a pain they share with all the loved
ones of the 53 sailors on board
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta